breaking tonight according to the hills
John Solomon we now have major evidence
of election collusion in 2016
real evidence to back it up this
collusion surrounds Hillary Clinton in a
top ukrainian government official that
wanted her elected we're gonna have all
the details coming up with John Solomon
but before we get to our top story ask
yourself a couple of questions is this
going to be investigated for three years
- by Muller won by the FBI and is in
Muller's case a married band of
Democratic donors will the mainstream
media even cover what is a damning story
with tapes we're not going to hold our
breath we have that story and so much
more tonight we first turn our attention
to Hannity watch on the alarming crop of
twenty20 Democratic hopefuls Democrats
are now pushing let's see to give 16
year-olds the right to vote you can't
drink till you're 21
promising to stack the Supreme Court
till they get enough justices that think
their way and will legislate from the
bench they're proposing an end to the
electoral college now what is happening
we will break it down this is a scary
attempt by politicians to centralize
power and control the lives of you we
the American people and right now it is
the party line among almost all the
Radical Democrats running to be
President in 2020 a blatant dramatic
frightening attempt to alter America in
ways that will make it unrecognizable
forever destroyed the greatest economic
wealth creation system in the history of
mankind now last night during a friendly
interview with so-called comedian Jimmy
Kimmel our old friend senator Kamala
Harris became the latest Democratic
candidate to express support for an end
to the electoral college take a look
senator Warren Elizabeth Warren had a
town hall last night and she said that
she thinks we should do away with the
electoral college is that do you agree
with that I think that it's open to the
discussion I mean there's no question
that the popular vote has been
diminished in terms of making the final
decision about who the press
the United States and we need to deal
with that so I'm open to the discussion
right now senator Harris Elizabeth
Warren Kirsten Gillibrand and many
Democrats support an end to the
constitutional process by which we have
always elected the President of the
United States so why is this a big deal
all right we turn quickly tonight to a
Hannity history lesson on the electoral
college to give you an explanation now
when our Constitution was drafted in
1787 the framers of the Constitution
they sought to rectify was a very
challenging conundrum how do you create
a limited central government strong
enough to defend its people against
serious threats but decentralized enough
to prevent consolidation and subsequent
abuse of power the result was a
constitution filled with checks balances
shared power between the individual
states the federal government the
electoral college is a product of this
system giving the states the power to
conduct elections and choose the
president as a result each state holds
some power in determining the executive
branch let me explain
without the electoral college and our
framers knew this small areas with dense
populations in other words New York New
Jersey Illinois California they wouldn't
monopolize the keys to the White House
and look at how all four of those states
have been destroyed by the people in
those states that elected liberal
socialist politicians everywhere else in
other words all of red America would
pretty much totally be ignored don't
take it from me listen to what Obama's
former campaign manager had to say about
this take a listen
just from a campaign manager standpoint
when I ran President Obama's campaign we
would never go to a small state if there
was no electoral college you'd go to the
major media markets you would not go to
Iowa you wouldn't go to Montana you
wouldn't go to New Hampshire you know I
think any proposal about getting rid of
the electoral college I understand that
concern and the concern is real that
we've had two presidents
get elected without winning a popular
vote but I agree with Charlie that's not
going to happen all right in other words
power would be totally consolidated with
scenario our free
our founders feared the most it's one of
the reasons look at the quote of Thomas
Jefferson he hated cities writing that
they're harmful to quote the morals the
health and the liberties of man he was
smart way ahead of his time and for
hundreds of years yes the electoral
college played an integral role in
decentralizing power of a central
government keeping the United States
United you think all those red states
would stick around and be in the United
States if they kept losing to New York
New Jersey California and Illinois I
tend to think not now Democrats don't
share the values of our framers they
want power for themselves and they want
it at all costs and that's why every
major proposal they're now pushing
begins and ends with their power and a
centralized federal government that they
control government-run health care a
complete takeover of the health care
industry yes run by the state remember
Kamala Harris and others they want to
end all private health care that impacts
200 million Americans I thought they
were pro-choice government-run education
now they're gonna add pre-k and college
education they haven't done a bad enough
job with kindergarten through twelfth
grade and they'll have government
consolidation of all guns and gun laws
government-run clean energy through the
government takeover of the energy sector
in other words they will take it over no
more oil and gas is their proposal for
10 years or we're going to die
government-run universal income
government paid for retirement
government paid for vacation
government-sponsored healthy food how
many of these 2020 candidates even want
government to control the means of
production in other words there were the
socialist green New Deal they proposed
that they'll tell you how to run your
business government promises for
everything for everybody you're gonna
now you'll never have a worry in the
world but you'll also give up all of
your freedom and all of the wealth
creation systems that we have built up
to this point in our history and we're
going to explain I'll even the poorest
in America have it so much better than
so many other people around the globe
all of a mini monologue detailing this
destructive what socialism mean what
this agenda would do to the country
later in the Pro
Graham will do something that well no
Democrat seems capable of will actually
do the math tell you how much your
paycheck the Democrats want to take it's
pretty close to a hundred percent and if
Democrats get their way this country as
we know it it's gonna be over it's done
it will not be the United States of
America as we know it all right but
first we turn our Hannity watch on the
Muller witch-hunt and we'll get to our
breaking news and another sign that the
probe is in its final stage special
counsel attorneys requested an extension
for a court filing related to the mana
four case because they were too busy
with quote the press of other work maybe
they're writing a report after nearly
three years now today President Trump
said he wants that report to be
available for all Americans take a
listen
let it come out let people see it that's
up to the Attorney General we have a
very good Attorney General is a very
highly respected man and we'll see what
happens
I want to see the report and you know we
want to see it the tens of millions of
people that love the fact that we have
the greatest economy we've ever had
I know nothing about it I know that he's
conflicted and I know that his best
friend is combing who's a bad cop and I
know that there are other things
obviously you know I had a business
transaction with him that I've reported
many times that you people don't talk
about but I had a nasty business
transaction with him and other things I
know that he put 13 highly conflicted
and you know very angry I call him angry
Democrats in with all of that being said
I look forward to seeing to repair
here's the ironic thing thanks to
Democrats after the impeachment of Bill
Clinton the president has no say
whatsoever in that decision whether to
make the findings public the Attorney
General and only the Attorney General
will decide tonight as we await them all
the report I want to get back to how
this all began this is important because
people need to absorb exactly what this
is all predicated on now according to
then lead FBI investigator Peter struck
and top FBI lawyer Lisa page after nine
months of an FBI investigation beginning
in July of 2016 there was they found no
evidence of Trump Russia collusion nine
months before Muller still after the
president rightly fired Comey which even
Comey acknowledges the president has to
do has the right to do for any reason or
no reason at all well then the deputy AG
rod Rosenstein well he appointed the
special counsel his friend Robert Muller
to continue the FBI's investigation into
so-called collusion remember Jeff
Sessions recused himself now Muller's
mandate was as follows investigate quote
any links and/or coordination between
the Russian government and individuals
associated with the campaign of
President Donald Trump and this part
that everyone seems to forget any
matters that arose or may arise directly
from the investigation now we've seen
Robert Muller prosecute various Trump
associates for processed crimes we saw
Muller prosecute Paul manna for for
crimes that had nothing to do with his
time with Trump Russia collusion and he
worked for the Trump campaign we watched
Muller prosecute a Russian
trol farm actually number of them filled
with people who will never be extradited
and tried in the United States to face
justice and Russian Intel people they
will never be tried they will never be
extradited but oddly enough we haven't
seen Muller prosecute matters that arose
from or involving Democrats or Clinton
allies where we asked tonight as the
Muller investigation into whether or not
the Clinton campaign used money and used
and funneled that money to an ex foreign
spy Christopher Steele who hated Donald
Trump who then colluded with Russia in
the development of the dirty dossier we
know the dossiers filled with Russian
lies and Ukrainian lies and total
propaganda where's the Muller
investigation into FISA abuse after all
there's clear and compelling and
incontrovertible evidence that a trump
campaign associate was spied on by
federal officials the bulk of the
information and the FISA application was
that Hillary bought and paid for Russian
dossier by the way and they never told
the court that Hillary paid for it where
is the Muller investigation into the
coordination in the effort of the State
Department to use the Clinton bought and
paid for Russian dossier to take down
Donald Trump who they wish didn't win
the election where's the Muller
investigation into uranium one remember
that case Russians we knew in the United
States because we actually had an FBI
agent in there that was reporting back
bribery kickbacks money laundering and
all sorts of racketeering we know Bill
Clinton at the time took a massive
payment from a Russian bank related to
uranium one and met with Vladimir Putin
in Russia we know the Clinton Foundation
raked in about one hundred and forty
five million dollars from uranium one
executives and we know Hillary Clinton
is Secretary of State well she was one
of a number of people signing off on
that deal the uranium one deal that's
right giving twenty percent of america's
uranium to Russia and Putin by the way
the foundational material for nuclear
weapons and we don't have enough on our
own we import uranium and where's the
Muller investigation into this damning
news story which we now get to tonight
from John Solomon we know tonight that a
high-ranking government of
official in Ukraine actively tried to
benefit the Clinton campaign in 2016
this is breaking tonight
according to Solomon Ukraine's top
prosecutor has opened a criminal probe
into whether senior law enforcement
officials in that country tried to sway
the u.s. election influence our election
to help Hillary Clinton win now a tape
recording released by a member of the
Ukrainian Parliament captured an
official talking about leaking Madoff or
financial records in the middle of the
2016 election for the stated purpose to
help Hillary Clinton a Ukrainian Court
even ruled the leak was an improper
effort to influence the American
election that's not all according to
this report by John Solomon Ukraine's
top prosecutor accused the u.s. embassy
of interfering in corruption
prosecutions inside the country
including one probe into the alleged
misuse of an American aid and a letter
surface from a senior member of Congress
to Secretary Pompeo accusing the current
US ambassador in Kiev of bad-mouthing
the Trump administration now this is
exactly what Mark Meadows was talking
about Tuesday on this show so where's
the Malheur investigation into these
matters
after all it's already under
investigation in the country Ukraine
there's a tape recording that has all
this information
where's equal justice under our laws
where's equal application of our laws
there was no Trump Russia collusion as
we now know from well the FBI told us
after nine months then of course the
house Intel committee told us and then
the Senate Intel committee told us and
as congressman Nunez pointed out many
years ago by the way 2014 it was among
many people by the way to do this
Russian interference he told us is a
real threat he warned us in 2014 and not
to can't not to the Trump campaign
instead by the way its power obsessed
Clinton's who may have been the most
susceptible that's where the real
collusion it ends up ends up being and
this week big news we learned that
former Obama White House Counsel great
Craig may soon be facing charges linked
of Muller's probe oh maybe a little
equal justice